on the mound for the halos record of
five and seven and a 4.10
era left-hander jose suarez who's
throwing the bump for his 10th start of
the season and he's looking for his
first career win here at the big a got
him
two down in the first
good change-up from suarez three
fastballs and then finished him off with
a really good change up this one is
down in the strike zone and gets kind of
philippa out on that front knee here's
the next pitch and there's a swing and a
miss and he got him struck him out
a nine pitch inning for suarez who
strikes out the final two in the inning
so half inning in the books here's otani
last night's winning pitcher going seven
innings allowing two runs and throwing a
career-high 117 pitches at the plate he
went over four and big high over the top
delivery and ohtani swings and pops one
up near the left field line coming on
hard is peters and he makes the catch as
charlie culberson peels out of the way
and he swings and it's a soft ground
ball to short charged by kind of full
effect it's a bad hop but gloves it
cleanly and pegs to first for the out
it's a one two three inning and we're
heading for the second rangers nothing
angels happening no score for one ending
jose suarez off to a good start nine
pitches and here's the pitch this is
bounced by the mound out near second
stop there by mayfield and he will
easily throw out low
so another quick out first five in a row
retired by jose suarez tonight here's
the pitch chops this one on the left
side stopping it is mayfield and the
throw is going to be in time and the
inning is over
so
three ground outs in the inning and that
was just an eight pitch inning jack
mayfield first up he was over two
yesterday drew a walk allards 2-2
and a swing and a miss his first
strikeout of the night one away here in
the second four up and four down for
colby allard in this scoreless game
in the pitch to walsh is swung on and
missed fastball up and in so uh
back-to-back strikeouts and here's the
pitch and adele it's a bouncing ball to
first low has it shovels to allard
covering it's a one two three inning and
we're going to the third nothing nothing
rangers and angels
one and two to culberson
and he goes down nice boy's got his
change up really really working suarez
gets strikeout number three he struck
out
three of the first seven and retired all
seven in a row no shift on with the
batter at the plate there's a swing and
a miss that a change-up struck him out
and that is how the inning will end
one go on here in the angels third and
juan lagarus will be the next batter 2-2
pitch hits this ball well into left
field that ball is carrying deep into
left field and it is out of here
and that's the first hit of the ball
game and the angels take a one-nothing
lead on gone with a home run
boy he got that fastball four-seen
fastball 18th home run versus fastball
for colby allard this year lakaris
fourth home run 31 are the eyes
here's the 2-1 and that ball is ripped
up the alley in left center a base hit
it will bounce three times and go up
against the wall leoti tearing around
the bases he's at second but he will put
on the stop right there one down on two
gets him big out right there still the
runner at third but two away and now dj
peters will be the batter
got him struck him out with a fast ball
and that is how the inning will end
first and second one down and a
one-nothing angels lead 2-2 pitch
lifted high in the air right center
field
circling under and making the catch on
that one is lagarus and the
lead runner low is holding so that's the
second out
routine play
jose trevino the catcher nine hole
hitter will be the next batter here's
the pitch
there's a fly ball lifted into shallow
left field godzilla is coming in still
coming in slides and he ends up making
the catch on that one play there saves
the run for sure had he not made the
catch they would have easily
gotten low in and who knows how far
culverson would have been able to
advance
for nothing the angels lead and connor
falefa is the batter here's the pitch he
swings at this one pops it in the air
into left field not deep at all under
waiting squeezing it will be gosling
that's the second out
here's the pitch a swing and a miss he
threw that one by him went after him
with a fastball struck him out
and that is how the inning will end he
has struck out garcia all three times up
tonight now the angels have two on with
nobody out and shohei at the plate and
here we go ohtani time
did he get it
he did
wow
donnie first pitch over at number 43
it is showtime
ohtani who pitched incredibly last night
for seven innings
hits a three-run home run
tonight what a phenomenal phenomenal
athlete shohei ohtani that baseball
was absolutely crushed
the 2-2 pitch shenadelle strikes out
swinging
and that will end the inning but the
damage done three runs more how about
jose suarez it's the deepest he's ever
gone in a ball game has been efficient
oh yeah
that's the eight strikeout of the night
gets peters looking second time he
struck out peters what a pitch
ground ball
red heapho
did he get him what a stretch he does
beautiful play two down let's go back to
that stretch by wallops that was a great
play by ibrahimo working all day long
on ground balls for brian butterfield
what a play this was suarez with the 2-1
pitch ground ball hit on the left side
backhanded by rendifoe and gets the
throw to first in time to end in a
best game of his big league career
tonight
there's a swing in the ground ball
through the whole left side of base hit
mayfield diving to his left couldn't get
it supposed on with one out here in the
eighth it's a four nothing angels lead
the rangers get their fourth hit ground
ball hit the short could be two second
one relay to first double play
and the inning is over
taylor made right
to ranhifo and that will wrap things up
here in the eighth
and here's the pitch
and it's hit on one hop to short renjifo
will throw to first in time for the out
but garcia picks up the rbi he's 78th
and the rangers are on the board they
will not be shut out tonight and all
that stands between jose suarez and a
complete game is dj peters
ground ball
he's everywhere fletcher across the
diamond and it is done
jose suarez
complete game first of the year for the
angels
what a performance and i love that right
there kurt suzuki jose suarez embracing
after a magical night for suarez first
home victory is a complete game victory
for suarez
you